on our top story this morning with the
prime minister expected to unveil a
major package to help with soaring
energy bills there's a campaign group
called don't pay uk which has been
calling for people to boycott paying
their bills altogether from october
unless they're cut to an affordable
level so will the pm's plans set out
today be enough
let's bring in one of the groups
organizers louis ford who joins us now
live louis ford good morning to you and
thanks for being with us so what kind of
level would bills need to be cut to but
don't pay uk to say they'll be right and
for them to then pay their bills
um so we're calling for 2021 levels so
back to april of last year before our 54
increase
okay so it's probably not going to get
near that is it
it doesn't look like at the moment um i
think
looking about two and a half grand so
you know fuel poverty's classes 10 of
your household income uh
so yeah average income 25 grand so we're
still looking at you know a lot of
people are going to be completely unable
to afford this you know we've got a lot
of people in fuel poverty already with
the current prices so
yeah we're still going to see a lot of
people struggling from this i think
and you'll still be campaigning then at
that point after we hear the
announcement today for people not to pay
their bills come the first of october
um it's looking that way if the if the
announcements that have been have been
rumored are coming then yeah i think so
um and you know we're not just
campaigning to stop paying bills we're
also building up local community support
networks things like mutual aid in order
to help people this winter who are going
to go
um without energy and who are going to
struggle
i'll come on to a bit of that work in a
minute but let me get this right we
still have the threshold that you guys
are waiting for for a million people to
join the campaign before you say
don't pay your bills
yeah so the most important thing for us
really is the number rather than the
date so
you know we know that 200 000 people so
far you know we've been heard you know
these demands have
drawn the attention of this government
and
you know things are being done so we
think with a million people the you know
the pressure that would apply we'd be
able to get to these you know more
affordable levels
yeah i mean it's the first time that um
i've been able to speak to you guys
does it feel like people have stopped
joining up to this are you happy with
the numbers that are still joining up to
the campaign
um we had 25 000 people sign up on
tuesday uh so you know we're we're still
seeing
we're still seeing the number going up i
mean i've got the ticker open on my
other on my other screen i can still see
people joining as we speak
i mean but you know the dangers of
people not paying their bills don't you
you know they'll be cut off and they
could end up being put onto what
for many will be a punitive uh pre-pay
meter
yeah i think that's the point isn't it
you know people are on pre-payment
meters and the people that typically on
these prepayment meetings are those who
have been unable to afford their bills
and yet they're put on
excuse me they're put on a tariff that's
more expensive than
you know your typical tariffs and then
if they can't pay
they get cut off no matter no matter the
situation you know
i suppose you're more traditional
uh
payment plan
you can negotiate with your with your
provider when you can't afford and they
don't you know they don't cut you off
whereas you know prepared meetings are a
punishment really aren't they for not
paying your bill
well it's a little bit more expensive
for people when they're on those
prepayment meters um
lewis just tell us about your situation
what what led you to
to join this movement and not just join
it but be a regional organizer
yeah i think it was just a accumulation
of
just
seeing my you know seeing my wedge get
squeezed and you know every time i felt
like i was doing better there was just
something behind me you know i'd i'd get
a pay rise the prices go up you know we
saw our shopping bill you know i've got
two young children um you know
we see our our bills go up each month
you know we do a food shop and then we
do the same food shop the next month and
it's more expensive and then you know
we're paying 350 pounds for our energy
bills since april and yet they're now
saying that we want us to pay 550 pounds
and if we do that then we're still going
to be in debt next year so
you know i saw the don't pay
campaign via social media and it was
spoken about and i just looked into it
and it you know
a collective action a collective
movement like this feels like the the
only way we can really
make this kind of change you know it's
the only way we can get listened to
individually we don't have
the power that you know we probably
should have in in this kind of democracy
but you know together we can actually do
something
and lose i would never tell you how to
live your life but i mean there are
other ways i guess to save money in the
household aren't there if you thought
and i guess you've been through all of
those things
we've we've done everything i mean with
octopus energy and they've been quite
good at kind of sending us tips on how
to on how to save energy you know
it's
we've been doing
anything we can really you know reducing
the amount of washing we do you know not
using the tumble dryer
there's all
there's all kinds of like little things
you can do you know
jumpers on during the house you know
we've not even seen the full effect of
of what this is going to be like yet
because you know we've had quite a warm
quite warm summer and our energy usage
is still at nearly 200 nearly 200 pounds
with all these little savings
so yeah i'm i'm a little bit worried for
winter and what that's going to bring
and you've got a family lewis as well
yeah
yeah yeah two young children just about
to get ready to do this school run
second day back
all right well i wish you all the best
lewis all right um thank you a regional
organizer from uh don't pay uk thank you